[Music]
[Laughter]
this show is brought to you by cash up
as you know cash up is a simplest way to
send and save money and now it's the
simplest way to try and grow your money
with cash up investing mm-hmm
I love cash up it's absolutely me Chris
D'Elia host of this congratulations
podcast it's my favorite way to send
money electronically
I even like doing it better than cash I
came people for back from it and I make
my opener pay me to open for me with you
by using cash app so I send and receive
I love it very easy to find the app -
it's like the easiest app to find on
your phone you know you're looking for
an app and you can't find it I hate that
it's the best brokerage services are
provided by cash app investing a
subsidiary of square and member si PC
and as always when you sign up for cash
up and use the promo code Congrats not
only will you instantly receive $10 but
cash app will also now donate ten
dollars to The Trevor Project an amazing
organization that provides crisis
intervention and suicide prevention
services to LGBTQ youth across America
download cash app from the App Store or
Google Play Store today
[Music]
see a Tatar hi
that's how that song today but yeah do
it whatever it's it it's it it's lit its
liddie dude I actually can't believe how
[ __ ] liddie it is it's 2020 and it's
so [ __ ] liddie but uh the the
follow-the-leader tour is over my babies
and that's why we got this in the
background right here we put up the
poster they gave it to me in Peoria
Illinois Peoria Civic Center theater
they made me that and they gave me that
and thanks a lot Pieria now where are
you why are people there went there for
some reason why max now it's all good
but we went to Peoria we went to Chicago
played in front of 14,000 people Chicago
thanks you're officially well boy might
be my favorite market one of my favorite
markets but I will tell you this still
called it's one of the most beautiful
cities if not I mean arguably the best
city in America
however caveat this just it this just in
this just in this just in we're talking
to you a lot live and this just in hold
on I'm getting something here
Chicago's too [ __ ] cold all good 20
degrees now it's 20 grease all good
how did jacket too [ __ ] heavy still
wind got in not only is it called
swindie people in Chicago move no I love
Chicago it's great busting your balls
but it's so so great it's just a great
great [ __ ] city man even cold it's
one of those places where every now and
then you'll see a guy not wearing a
jacket because he thinks he's the
[ __ ] tough guy and you just want to
lay him the [ __ ] out you know you just
want to lay him out you just want to be
like hey bud why are you not horizontal
going on you only only only only only
only oh you know they used to when you
used to go boy
on the [ __ ] cartoons there go blowing
and the guy will go in and play like an
accordion as he walked
that's real that really happens if you
do that to a guy what if you were in a
fight and you were like all right come
on buddy and you [ __ ] went to go
clobber him like over the head and you
hit him on the top of the head and then
he won POW and walked away I'm I ain't
oh and that's what this podcast is about
go listen to NPR you know anyway dude my
one fire just brought up Wiley coyote
and Roadrunner best moments you know
it's a cartoon so anyway yeah went to
Chicago and it was great did three shows
because we had to [ __ ] double it up
and double it up and keep Dublin until
the kill me and so we had one show that
in we're gonna do them all in July and
then we could only do one cuz I had to
shoot that movie uh army of the Dead
that hasn't come out yet
and then so we moved the rest of the
three over to New Year's Eve and they
all sold out so it was awesome it was
actually [ __ ] awesome to be in there
in in [ __ ] Chicago or if you're real
[ __ ] you'd be like shy town or how
Atlanta same people would say Hotlanta
says shy town I say Chicago in Atlanta
anyway and for Peoria I say why are
there so did it on New Year's Eve but
the ball dropped my balls dropped and
then [ __ ] stayed in Chicago for a
wedding in the next week and we were in
Chicago for [ __ ] too long and it was
too cold and my [ __ ] lips were
chapped and my nose were chapped and
[ __ ] nice dude my nose is chapped not
just on the bottom but and the upper
part dude nice [ __ ] yeah dude oh my nose
was so chapped yes dude you ever have
your nose chapped people are on their
lips chapped [ __ ] [ __ ] that I leveled it
up it's 20/20 my nose is chapped not
even the bottom bro the top that's like
at the end of the ticket what's that
Matthew McConaughey movie in court where
you got big and famous for it time to
kill is that what it was and he's just
like
going on and on and then your daughter
was raped and then she was killed and
then she was beat up and then now
imagine now imagine she was wide at the
end and you were just like that's what
it was for me when I did that and then
my nose is chapped my lips to chairman
nose job
now imagine it's at the top and everyone
goes guilty [ __ ] [ __ ] yup that's me dude
Makana has lost his mind dude his
Instagram is just [ __ ] absolutely in
charge Matthew McConaughey Instagram is
a say in charge bro
let's just go looks like a [ __ ] and
guess what it is and celebrate that
person's gift somebody open somebody
doesn't want to tear the wrapping paper
so they open it up real slow
tags right here it could be tagging it
up [ __ ] killing dude absolutely
murdering open-mike that would be an
open mic joke and Matthew McConaughey
just [ __ ] killed it and guess if he's
wearing a blue suit with a blue vest
under it and a blue undershirt with a
white collar dude guess if that is true
and if you guessed yes
you'd be right dude it
so [ __ ] it is so [ __ ] Texan and
also Connecticut to [ __ ] wear a blue
button-down with a white collar it is so
[ __ ] unbelievable Matthew McConaughey
I'm telling you I can't wait until I'm
this kind of famous and I will be dude
just so I can do these kinds of things
bro
now the problem is you know when he does
the real [ __ ] let's just look at his
Instagram I think he's just so great man
by the way big phenomenal actor like
straight up busting his balls but the
best just real good and if anyone says
he's not good eat a dick now does he
dress like a [ __ ] Superman villain
yes always to look at this [ __ ] green
jacket he has an Instagram with the
green turtleneck bro I gotta get a
turtleneck man I swear I put on a
turtleneck the other day and and
everyone went oh I didn't buy it because
it was [ __ ] bro I put on a turtleneck
uh two grand it was two grand and I go
like this okay not gonna buy this wow
there's a picture of Matthew McConaughey
on his Instagram with Matthew
McConaughey and and and what's a Woody
Harrelson in a in a lake of course there
is one thing's for sure Matthew
McConaughey has never [ __ ] a guy he's
had sex with 40 women and that's it
could add sex with way more but he's
Josiah he's not the kind of guy I am
it's not the kind of style I do always
rolling a booger to when he's talking
one time when I was in my in my 20 was
in high school my girlfriend broke up
with me broke my heart and then she
started dating a Mormon guy and and she
said he reminded them of Matthew
McConaughey and ever since then I think
about that all the time and it's all
good so anyway and it's all good did she
say because his voice sounded like
[ __ ] warm molasses and that's such a
stupid thing to say for a [ __ ] 18
year old yes is it all right it is
now was it for a few years no now the
problem is now the problem is getting a
[ __ ] in the beginning of the movie if
you're watching it in the beginning of
it goes like this
2020 getting sucked and doesn't show the
[ __ ] it doesn't show his ways cuz
he's getting sucked well always shot
every Instagram video he's ever done
twice he did it once and he goes nine I
like that one let's try it again and
then did it and then [ __ ] was I yeah
that's fine
and he always thought I could do a
better but what am I gonna keep doing it
that's what he thought every day I know
this dude this is the important [ __ ] in
life man this is the important [ __ ] in
life it's not what the [ __ ] war on
Iran it's not the [ __ ] you know I
mean the Australia fires are pretty
[ __ ] important but this is the
important [ __ ] dude this we don't really
know what's going on out there
we don't know do you really know if we
should be a war with [ __ ] Iran or not
do you really know you got Fox News
saying one thing you got CNN saying the
other thing but you got me telling you I
know for a fact just by looking at it
that Matthew McConaughey only films
Instagram videos twice that's this [ __ ]
we need to know let's start there dude
set it on Instagram dude let's watch it
again the beginning up in 2020 what's
that about getting sucked
well the 2019 was if you did I'm looking
for 2020 to be a lot cooler because we
do running for office you see that
running for office dude did it twice
how did that the second time I know how
to make it pop did that see you there or
dude Wow
see you there is so something Matthew
McConaughey would say [ __ ] at the end
instead of see you next year he doesn't
know I like it's kind of corny we say
see you next year I said see there they
see there that's kind of one of my
things
if 2019 was be a lot cooler if you did
2020 was a lot cooler like cool that you
did it
a lot of cooler coolers get our coolers
2020 but bigger the coolers preparing
our colors and then somebody just
comments my platonic love heart eyes
okay what's going on your brain broken
dude so many people's brains of brokens
it's unbelievable it's [ __ ]
unbelievable that people's brains are
broken for real what's Tom Hanks his son
Chet Chet Hanks Chet Hanks do you see
what he said at [ __ ] some bumbaclot
mmm well what happened whitney's sent
this to me hold on where is it
why is Tom Hanks on Chet's became bigger
toys patwa cool it's French big up the
whole island massive it's a boy
stephannie coming straight from that
Golden Gloves yo ro that the action
second Golden Globes like dude Golden
Gloves is the whitest thing I have
her golden globes wiggle wiggle
big up the whole island massive it's a
boy
Athena coming straight from that Golden
Gloves or10 big up to the whole island
he says I think we go big up the whole
island massive it's a boy
Athena coming straight from that Golden
Gloves Oh our tail
we didn't fight atomic position in our
watch so far what come bigger mean
absolutely saying nothing and even
people from patois people who speak
patois r like this that was why Tom hex
was making that face it was just a laid
by the way at the Golden Globes and he
was like because he because he just saw
his son on Twitter gonna be cousin they
move beyond the area yeah big up mister
on step by step movie on the area snow
this Informer informa yes no silly
mister say I complain I'm Alec hippo mum
there yeah wake up the whole island
Chaitanya it dad's Tom Hanks dude oh he
does another 100 I didn't know it
come on infinite oh I didn't know why
are you doing this
pick up the youth then we're at the
Kings done wake up this moment and we
see the pain tunnel internet gone mad
respek you don't know this one far what
I got I didn't know it's gonna be that
sexy dude her set it on the way out a
smoothie king not even joking
walking out a smoothie king oh my god
nobody has ever said [ __ ] it come out
of smoothie king and said you would then
we came out a smoothie king yo big up
dude I like how he came a little quiet
at smoothie king he was like I know
people don't do this normally but big
about the smoothie king to Rhode Island
massive uh Wow uh somebody said blame
Drake wow that's funny dude why does he
speak in on why is he speaking on that
also how old is this guy shouldn't he be
a lot older
I've been sitting him this age for a
long time hmm he's only 29 huh Wow he
has music right wow that's cool man oh
man you know what if my son grows up to
be like that I'm gonna [ __ ] do that
with him he's gonna be like I'm gonna be
like this that's right beagle beagle
let's go what you want huh you wanna go
to Jamboree are we going to Jamboree
built my son here for Jamboree to me I
mean my self-respect and my buddies
crystal eh it Leonia me that is crystal
iyanya that's why what happened when
Portilla when put in my pants
yeah that's what happened
but what happened I went to potty and
diarrhea in my boxers yeah I got made
that's where still we're in the DI
purser me that didn't stay outside while
I was on well I well I was in
kindergarten yeah sorry I was
he said he was gonna wait for me in case
I got scared left I pick me it out the
door and he left and I got scared and I
pooped in me pooped in me the airport
when the area
Boyka Boyka Wilma firetruck what happen
excuse me I'm a little cranky miss me
nap time where's my goddamn fire truck
booyaka booyaka util where wow dude love
it
Wow Chet Hanks dude he writes on
Instagram officially blasted what does
it take to be officially blasted dude
man he got inked up huh
I got to get officially blasted for real
I'm only partially blasted I got blasted
on my [ __ ] booyakasha and on my
[ __ ] big old a movie on the Erie
around the air but I need to get [ __ ]
officially blasted I just need to get
the Batman insignia on my chest and just
get officially blasted
patois put toys you know that's what I
said whoopsie so racist man I love it
dude it's 2020 man it is 2020 how much
does Matthew I sort of got gonna be like
this 2020 man funniest thing about that
is I got 20/20 vision yeah I got 20
that's my high my eye sight for the
future for 2020 is exactly what year it
is 2020 vision
let's do it again they does again he
says that's it I don't do it again
oh the freaks come out at night
um I get I got I got I get a lot of
emails dude I'm not trying to brag but I
get a lot of [ __ ] emails so that's
fine and you guys it's all good but I
get a lot of a [ __ ] I get more emails
than you and I definitely more you
Muslim Bryan Callen and also even though
I even though I do I check him way more
than Bryan Callen dude I sent Bryan the
[ __ ] video too
you know how I want to go on him
I went to Phoenix and surprised them the
video is up by the way you can go look
at it
but I went to go put my thing on I put
it on YouTube and I was like here you go
Brian put it up and the guy just takes
too long man
this is why he's not playing [ __ ] big
theaters because your fans don't feel
like they can connect with you because
you're not on it bro get on it boyacá
big old Brian Carla there get on there
dude get online and [ __ ] tweet do
your [ __ ] stop posting 45 photos on
[ __ ] Facebook bro mmm oh when he did
that we talked about this on time in a
podcast the og [ __ ]
but dude he posted the best tweet of all
time is Bryan Callen I post let me get
it the best tweet of all time this is
the best tweet of all time dude
booyaka the best tweet of all time now
close all these bullshit's because I
hate when they have them up and it's all
good but it still happens and it's all
good
best tweet of all time right here here
we go
where is it Bryan here we go yeah here
it is aw dude I was laughing so hard
this is still the greatest thing ever
happening there Bryan Callen from June
July 29th 2013 I posted 45 photos on
Facebook in the album Chicago Improv
Sunday that was a tweet he did dude who
gives a [ __ ] imagine 45 photos on
Facebook from Twitter he posted it
Chicago Improv Sunday is miniscule
nobody's gonna click on that [ __ ]
it had no tree tweets and no likes and
then i retweeted it now it's got some
from [ __ ] six years ago obviously it
has some but do it I mean the photos are
great just people just him with people
none of these people even gave a [ __ ]
you know people half the people thought
he was like just like we're going to see
him because they liked him once on
Veronica's closet
Wow do it
sir 90s that they made a sitcom called
Veronica's closet because of victoria's
secret
boyish ah anyway uh here we go O'Brien
can't still post like that back then
okay cool
support for congratulations comes from
manscaped who is the best in men's below
the belt grouping grooming grouping or
grooming grooming manscaped offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels and that means your nuts
it's 2020 and you know what that means
new year new me new balls well same
balls but new balls being the way I
shave him listen up men hairy bushes are
so 2019 arguably they're very 70s even
so what you doing living that far in the
past if you're going to pick any new
year's resolution this year let it to be
take care of your junk manscaped is
making it easy with their grooming
products shaving your balls is scary it
is I I sweat when I do it mostly because
I'm also lifting weights when I do it
but some of us do it some of us do it
you know I'm not gonna name names but
we've had accidents in the name Chris
D'Elia manscaped has redesigned the
electric trimmer the lawn mower 2.0 has
a proprietary I thought were so hard to
say yes but it's got a proprietary skin
safe technology so this trimmer won't
Nick or snag your nuts isn't that
amazing get 20% off free shipping with
the code congrats at manscaped comm
start the new year off right by what
using the right way by using the best
tools for the job
your balls will thank you get $20 20%
off and free shipping with the code
congrats at manscape comm that's 20% off
with Free Shipping at manscape calm and
use code congrats bowl and branch I love
bold and branch sheets because I never
wake up in the middle of the night too
cold or too hot it's awesome it's
actually amazing I guess they use maybe
science or magic but to the softest and
most comfortable sheets in the world and
the only bedding loved by three US
presidents see if you can guess who they
are
I'll give you hint one isn't John Adams
he died long long time ago for limited
time you can get their luxury flannel
bedding to keep you cool sleepers warm
and because they breathe keep the warm
sleepers cool
uh have you ever had linen sheets
p-diddy probably does you need to try
them if you haven't while you're there
you can check out all the other amazing
stuff by Bolin branch-like there
mattress towels and much more shipping
is always free you can try them out for
30 nights 30 nights risk free and right
now you can get $50 off your first set
of sheep sheets at bol and branch comm
with promo code Congrats
get $50 off and bow at Boland branch
comp remote Congrats that's bol LBO LL
it's spelled bol el and branch com code
congrats anyway but you could show you
know it's all good but so the so the
D'Elia so it's on my youtube D'Elia
crashes Kalen set subscribe to my [ __ ]
by the way so ya pocket our podcast is
killing dude it's killing people are
watching and listening more than ever
the babies are growing and that's
because of me okay of course but also
you guys are helping okay let's look I'm
not gonna be like this would this
podcast exist if it wasn't for you guys
yeah I just wouldn't film it or even
record it it would just be me walking
around talking sometimes I wouldn't even
say this stuff I would just keep it in
my head but now it exists out there for
the public because of you that's where
you guys come in now it exists because
of me I'm not gonna be like one of those
corny [ __ ] that's like I
couldn't do this without you of course
dude but I could I could but it wouldn't
be recorded it's recorded because of you
and you help grow this cult you guys
help grow this cult you guys keep it so
my pockets are fat making fun of Matthew
McConaughey if it wasn't for you guys my
pockets go on a diet all right now we
need my pockets to be bulging like that
ass on Instagram you saw my [ __ ] did you
you saw my [ __ ] I didn't
my ass look like that but it does dude
I've got that wagon on me
I really do I walk backwards and you
you'd swear was 1812 I walk backwards
and you'd swear was 1812 because a
stagecoach was coming if you see me at
the park with my dogs you think is it
1812 you go hole up is it 1812 and then
someone says what and they say look up
there's a stagecoach for some horse oh
never mind that's just Crystal Lea with
his dogs because oops I got that wagon
on me um yeah but my [ __ ] is thick bro
for a tall drink of water
dude look me in my faces same eye I
don't have that wagon on me
look me in my face and say for a tall
drink of water I don't have that wagon
on me what's that noise Chris is backing
up what's that noise dude
Chris is coming to get ya what's that
noise dude my ass holds a mouth I see a
plate of food you kidding me I'm running
for [ __ ] mayor one day for real swear
to God and I'm gonna use that clip as my
[ __ ] commercial in black and white
like how they they're gonna try and diss
me do you really want a guy and I go and
and I'm gonna have it like that and just
me going oh my ass was a mouth I got
that wagon on me you you think it's 1812
and then it's me and I go like this
yup you're goddamn right you do vote for
me hell yeah dude
and I'm so serious dude
so anyway dude that's right I do have a
wagon on me and I don't know what I was
talking about it kind of devolved into
the thing go up here
move out up move it on up there we go
anyway I have an Instagram you can
follow me it doesn't it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter I have over 2 million
followers on Instagram and over Wi-Fi
made over one that I got over 1 million
on Twitter so that's great dude so
that's good alright but yeah dude hmm a
lot of people started commenting all you
is a big show the show on Netflix you is
a big show a lot of people are
commenting commenting Hendy you know I
played this creep Henderson or handy on
you and a lot of people are watching
this [ __ ] it's crazy how big the show is
um but thanks for watching because it's
cool this [ __ ] uh I got a I got a I got
a um I gotta I gotta I gotta figure out
what to do next you know I'm glad I got
other things coming my [ __ ] my my
what do you call it my special is coming
out just got a tentative date for that
and it's in a few months guys sit sit
still it'll come out don't know what I'm
gonna call it yet not sure don't know
what i'ma call yet not sure but it's
coming let's see what else happened here
in and the thing dude did you guys see
that Pope slap my god I've never seen
something so [ __ ] I've never seen
something so [ __ ] I mean first of all
you know something is gonna be so [ __ ]
when it has to do with a 90 [ __ ]
something your old man you know what I
mean I don't know how the old the Pope
is how come a pope can't be [ __ ] 22
you know why is the Pope always need to
be a hundred and ten look at this look
she won't let go hey hey yeah yeah yeah
hell yeah do it that's gangster he
didn't hurt her dude here's the thing
man you probably pulled his arm out of
the socket and I got pissed that would
piss look at this look
she grabs him this is a slow-motion she
grabs him ow he hurts him this idiot
let go dude she makes me mad she
deserved a little [ __ ] on her hand
that's what you get dude what if he just
[ __ ] decked her face what if he goes
ah and just goes and she get and she
goes bloody and she goes like this oh
and everyone goes oh and it goes [ __ ]
and walks away and you heard it quietly
Wow dude imagine that I here's the thing
there's a thing I'm not religious at all
I'm not Catholic I grew up Catholic
but then when I had to go to church so
much and everyone the and the [ __ ]
church and the Pope and the priest was
always going I'm like I I'm a head out
you know here we go man I wish I was my
meanie now as I was then
because I would be as a kid I would just
be like stop doing that or if they broke
you mean you're not gone
nice cookies and let me tell you
something no no I'm not religious if the
Pope goes ah and then smacked and and
and and then smacked her like that and
then and then walked off now he says
Pope Francis sorry for hitting women's
hand on New Year's bro if the Pope goes
like this
guess what she got what she deserved
not sorry all of a sudden I'm religious
okay
I'm thinking a vow of celibacy I'm not
[ __ ] my girl I'm a pope okay I'm a
pope
I'm Oh what do you call it priests all
of a sudden I became a priest because
that's respect did stand by for stand by
what you do that's why Ricky Gervais
Snead's to be the Pope he killed it it's
so funny people let me tell you
something he really killed it from all
app he was killing it everyone was
laughing not everyone was laughing but
the [ __ ] were not laughing a lot of
people in Hollywood need to save face
and they can't be seen laughing at
that [ __ ] but you know that shit's funny
this article opinion ricky gervais on
the independent ricky gervais steeping
the golden globes in overshadowed vital
political statements from the ho from
who a guy with a show on hulu hey dude
see ya from oh the chick from [ __ ]
fargo cachi who gives a [ __ ] about an
actor saying anything that they wrote
that's so annoying and another thing in
times like these this is a test what you
don't give a [ __ ] Gervaise killed it
it was sharp it was on point he was
funny and confident dude here's the
other thing they're acting like he
cheapened it some people the fringe is
acting like what he did was immature do
you know how hard what he did is the
answer's no I know how hard what he did
is because I'm a comedian
it is so [ __ ] hard to roast a roomful
of people
at them about them and make them laugh
at all and he did that also no political
statements from actors are vital whoever
whatever cuck wrote this is just
unbelievable dude I'm so tired of
chucking ass [ __ ] just so tired
a cut can ask [ __ ] but guess
what we found somebody posted this I
told you I posted
is that all job interview is not over
yet hello he said bender Bo hey Soto job
interviews not over yet I told you we'd
find it the babies came through dude how
did the Adhan how did he had a bee in
front of interview but that's some
gangster [ __ ] uh so yeah did that Pope
slap though I got to get religious I
wish he did well why'd you grab me like
that all right you [ __ ] grab me like
that critics dude critics at all though
critics at all like to critic criticize
they don't understand they most of the
time make it worse for themselves like
it's just gonna add fuel to the fire oh
this was a good one dude take this guy
oh this was a good one they did it off
on me somebody reviewed my act in
Chicago I tweeted it somebody wrote
where is it he said my stuff I talked a
lot about I talk a lot about what do you
call it the sensitive times and how it's
okay to make jokes and [ __ ] like that
and the guy was was saying I shouldn't
my whole my whole Act to say people get
offended at everything people get
offended at stuff that I say in my act
and it's not offensive that's my whole
point and somebody wrote and this guy
wrote this whole thing was like yeah it
was funny and Chris D'Elia did a lot of
funny stuff for whatever the [ __ ] but it
really took a turn down turn for the
worse and became not funny when he
started talking about how people are
offended at things when he doesn't even
have offensive material oh hey do
are you making my point for me that's
exactly what the joke is is that I'm not
offensive yet people are offended and
also because I do get all the time
people say on the fence of all the first
of all you listen this podcast you guys
have never heard this podcast I say that
I say [ __ ] that people get here look
there it is and I was making fun of
critics in the thing I say hey look a
critic being upset that I'm making fun
of critics the fact that he said it was
funny until I brought it up I love [ __ ]
like this I was waiting for it can't
wait till people I have this one bit in
my act that people will blog about
sometimes about how it's offensive and
[ __ ] and then I cuss that happened I
started talking about it in my act and I
start commenting on the times and how
everyone's sensitive to everything and
how and this guy was like are just so
missing the point
it's amazing how much critics can just
they just don't get it do it you know
what I mean and I'm not trying to be
defensive I understand this probably
sounds defensive you know if you're a
hater of mine or whatever the [ __ ] but
like dude to say you're making my point
for me how does that happen how does
that happen that somebody misses a point
so glaringly obvious yeah it's just
someone saying I say people's I say in
my act like people get so mad for people
saying certain things and it's
ridiculous and then the critic says it's
so ridiculous he sayings that we can't
say something you know why cuz what you
have isn't a job that's why if you
criticize comedy it's not a job I don't
know the guys name but it's probably
[ __ ] Spencer or some [ __ ] you know
but anyway it's so on Unreal 11 it which
one is it
post mates when you need red wine at 4
p.m. sushi at 9 p.m. and a breakfast
burrito at 8 a.m. and ibuprofen at 10
a.m.
post made it post mates is your personal
food delivery grocery delivery whatever
kind of delivery service all year round
anything you're craving post mates can
deliver they're the largest on demand
network in the US and offer delivery
from all the restaurants grocery and
convenience stores and traditional
retailers you could possibly want to
need ordered it last night 24 hours a
day 365 days a year
post bikes will bring what you need with
within the hour no more trips to the
store I mean it's great I use it all the
time you don't even have to know where
the store is plus makes I'll deliver
anything to you download the app for iOS
or Android for free browse local
restaurants and businesses and track
your delivery in real time for a limited
time postmates says giving our listeners
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app and use code
Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post mates out
anything you need anytime you need a
post made it
download post mates well you might as
well do it right now and then put in the
code Congrats and you'll get that that
reward right there
congratulations is brought to you by
cash app the official app of the log
cabin uh yeah dude so it's just weird
it's like being like I don't even
whatever
everyone's so insane and they think
their opinion matters so much it's so
insane like what Rose McGowan wrote on
Twitter
he's just these people don't realize
that they're helping the exact opposite
size side that they think they're
hurting the
can I rent imagine giving a [ __ ] you
know what maybe giving a [ __ ] about Rose
McGowan and what she said about Iran is
not that far-fetched or crazy people
care what people say but here dear Iran
the USA has disrespected your country
your flag your people 52% of us humbly
apologize well that's not true we want
peace with your nation we are being held
hostage by a terrorist regime we do not
know how to escape please do not kill us
what do you mean that's as simple as it
is what do you mean you can go anywhere
you have a passport
you got money and I hate that hole if
you don't like it then leave because you
have a life here you're not gonna leave
I get it you can complain about the
country obviously it's initiated some
people think it's in the [ __ ] fine I
don't even have a take issue with that
but if you were ever gonna say if you
hated them leave to anyone this [ __ ]
one right here I mean 52% of us humbly
apologize
it broke don't put me in any percentage
okay do scream seven we are being held
hostage the [ __ ] Gaul dude how about
people who have been held hostage
reading that with like limps and [ __ ]
and their tongue missing just like Wow
huh
they're just like what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Diller just thinking do you scream seven
some guy without a tongue in the [ __ ]
Philippines just like those grim problem
just so ridiculous to tweet something
like that
and it's so weird that people got she's
so angry see that's the thing people
don't she she is legitimately growing
the right she's she's mobilizing the
right she is she what she basically did
was you know how I take the Metamucil to
congeal my [ __ ] bowel movements
that's what she did to the right on that
tweet
she's the Metamucil for the for the
right
she's the Metamucil for the GOP that's
what she did right there she just goes
hey 52% and the right just one like this
come on come on come on we gotta get
together we gotta get together oh you
are you on the you don't know you're not
sure if you're with us or not you just
decided you are okay cool come on in
here we go now let's [ __ ] get this
ready that's what she did it's
unbelievable that people [ __ ] uh-uh
about his [ __ ] it's unbelievable she
said that I stopped listening we stopped
listening to myself because I just read
a headline that said the baby was
arrested in little cuffs oh wow dude the
baby and his crew there's a rapper
that's really popular named the baby the
baby post a message on his followers on
IG about his recent arrest please stop
talking to me about that we cast 48
hours I spent in jail and that failed
attempt to break my spirits and
interrupt the path you know what dude
how about this I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
not reading the rest of it okay baby
there's also little baby okay guys
figure it out one of you guys changed
your name to Carl I [ __ ] was at the
coffee bean the other day this is what I
want to talk about and this is a real
thing dude okay I want to talk about
this I was at the coffee bean the other
day and this girl I know saw me said hi
hugged me and then that's it
the whole rest of the day I smelled like
goddamn perfume ladies I can do that
why doing that
while you pour in a whole bottle of
Cologne on your left shoulder why doing
that dude it's so and that's that to me
that's the equivalent of the guy picking
the party that picking the guitar up at
the party and playing for everybody why
do I have to smell what the [ __ ] you
want to smell wake up
shower get dressed get out why do i why
does my nose have to [ __ ] be under
attack
by what the [ __ ] you think I should it
should smell dude I'm letting everybody
smell what the [ __ ] they want I'm not
telling you what the smell do I [ __ ]
rub smoky meats all over my [ __ ]
fantastic shirt before I walk out of the
day cuz I want people to smell smoking
meats know so don't do it with perfume
dude perfume [ __ ] sucks it sucks man
it makes my eyes water
it makes my right shoulder smell like I
want to smell like high school all day
long the chick [ __ ] that I used to
date in high school she wore that [ __ ]
heaven from the gap [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and now I got to smell like a [ __ ]
department store cuz I'm at the coffee
bean and some girl thought she would
pour half a bottle of whatever the [ __ ]
it is some gold [ __ ] you know some gold
looking perfume that she just doused on
her right shoulder and now I got a smell
like it because I went to guide to site
because she decided to [ __ ] terrorize
my nostril you know how annoying that is
to put perfume on you think you're
better than someone if you put perfume
on here we go everyone smell what's nice
you don't know what I think is nice put
the guitar down we're all talking over
the conversation and you're gonna just
spritz it up I'm at a [ __ ] cafe man
chemicals and [ __ ] when you spray your
[ __ ] like that and you walk in and I hug
you I'm the Jordan crying mean it's so
annoying dude Cologne and then this is
the time to kill
now imagine it's Cologne
now imagine it's a guy guilty guilty
send him away for life two life
sentences back-to back when they say
back to the to life sentence back to
back shut up just say forever
nah but it has to be official and we're
our robes
I [ __ ] all in myself dude cologne guy
what you doing you choosing how I'm
gonna smell huh Joe you choosing how I'm
gonna smell some guy is that right Adam
now I'm Chris and I'll smell what the
[ __ ] I want
don't rub [ __ ] smoky meats on me all
this makes so much sense I swear to god
it's [ __ ] it I love you guys man I
probably don't love all you I like a lot
of you do it I probably don't even like
a lot of you but a lot of you guys some
of you guys I probably like a [ __ ]
few you guys and you know what I'm so
glad that you're thinking about you're
listening to this podcast and I'm gonna
keep I got to keep it real for you guys
okay Patricia Arquette powerful Golden
Globe speech ISM and hurt bro okay I
didn't hear that
I'm gonna actually listen to it I didn't
hear the Patricia Arquette powerful
Golden Gloves speech text it to me now
but oh my god open it I didn't hear it
yet now I did not hear Patricia
Arquette's
powerful Golden Globe Shh go ahead since
we now yeah but I will say text it on
fire and I'm pissed
can't text I can't text it now the
reason why I can't text it is because
because I'm pissed okay
and causes one fire now it's not showing
up on my notes which is making me what
even more pissed yes my lats are sore
cuz I did back yesterday and I [ __ ]
killed it and you think I give a [ __ ]
about if you guys think that that's
[ __ ] where is it in my notes it's
not oh there it is
okay cool got it got it got it right
here
got it right here overreacted so look so
Patricia Arquette's powerful golden
glow' speech is a must watch now okay
let's just play it first and it's 49
seconds 20 20 let's listen let's listen
no no it's very important to listen to
what she has to say about the world in
political politically because she was in
that [ __ ] movie with Gabriel Byrne
where it was about a [ __ ] person
getting possessed okay now let's listen
we're not gonna look back on this night
in the history books we will see a
country on the brink of war okay and
action states in America okay and cut
someone should run up and just sit and
comment tweeting out a threat of 52
bombs including cultural sites young
people who's clapping you know who's
clapping way way way way way less people
than we're laughing at Ricky Gervais
okay so don't so a independent suck on
those taters travelling across the world
people not knowing if bombs are gonna
drop on their kids heads and a little
bit weird saying I love my kids so much
I beg of us all to give them a better
world for our kids and there were people
clapping we have to vote in and plead
for everyone we know to vote in 2020
thank you Hey but I'll sign hey II hey
here's my rebuttal you were in stigmata
hey here's my rebuttal you were in the
movie stigmata I mean when I was a kid
thinking what the [ __ ] is stigmata
just alright you know also I mean saying
it with [ __ ] sunglasses on how are we
gonna take you serious when your
cleavage is sky-high
when your cleavage goes past your
forehead
oh man this [ __ ] podcast huh we're at
babies
oh man
I'll tell you what if I if I was the
host which I never will be of the Golden
Globes naturally natch
that's nice - after that I would have
been like this Lost Highway other hood
holes stigmata Nightmare on Elm Street
Little Nicky true romance Toy Story for
flirting with disaster Uncle Buck
bringing out the dead goodbye lover you
were in all these movies what'd you say
don't count anyway we'll be back right
after these messages
ant-man Anna the nine hundred and
eightieth Golden Globes will be back
with Gabriel Byrne and Halle Berry with
short hair around wreck again those
corny ask me musics you know that they
do what the [ __ ] is that
whatever rips um I mean what I got a
winner you know what I don't want to win
a Golden Globe for the clout I don't
want to win an Emmy or a [ __ ] Oscar
for the cloud I want to I want to win it
for the [ __ ] speech dude I want to
win it for the speech I want to win it
so it goes Chris D'Elia for plant when
Chris Thalia his first win for playing a
Japanese man with no makeup in the movie
you know in the movie revenge
hey honey here you go hey what's going
on thanks for this it was all me
and then I go [ __ ] with my [ __ ]
fingers but way too far like not like
this how people do it like up way too
[ __ ] far like some bully in the 80s
and in a movie you'd see and you'd be
like well it doesn't even how you do it
I keep my foot middle fingers up and I
go like this and I go like this as I
walk offstage I do I flip the bird do it
I keep repeatedly flipping the bird dude
that's what I do
I love it though man I hope I went I
hope one day I win I'm a dude I'm in
Hollywood though baby I'm in Hollywood
and that's how we do and I never won't
be in Hollywood I bet I got my podcast
going thank you for coming out to see me
you guys
Chicago ripped man Peoria was okay what
did Quintin speech do this is a good one
it's an old one really when today this
week this year I really did well bring
it up my baby Quentin Tarantino speech
we're gonna play a little bit here one
fire [ __ ] prematurely wrote Quinn's
speech and I got excited and didn't have
the link but it's all good God here we
go best grandpa that I mean I think but
was only Margo giving me the award that
was the Mojo that pushed it over the
edge dude
he's awesome
why is it not playing I want to dedicate
this award to the Dean of screenwriters
Robert bolt and very nice
my favorite screenwriter growing up that
made me want to be a screenwriter was
John Milius and John and John Milius is
hero was Robert bolt so I'm proximally
oh so right here right now he's old
normally the thing is when I'm with a
writing award and you don't share the
script with somebody else you write it
by yourself you kind of only have
anybody to thank I did it yeah
[Applause]
but this time more than usually most I
had a fantastic cast and it's not just
the BS fantastic cast it was a fantastic
cast that took it from the page and had
to add a slightly different layer than
what was just on the page whether it was
Leo in the trailer whether it's a brad
having his acid flashback acid acid trip
or Marga wrote it you know dude that's
awesome he's awesome
love him I couldn't turn he was awesome
imagine working with him how [ __ ]
awesome that would be okay also there
was a I'm gonna go but first I want to
say this a palm reader was arrested for
allegedly convincing a client that her
daughter was possessed by a demon and
swindling her out of 71 thousand dollars
police say
okay arrest the client arrest the client
you deserve to be in jail you [ __ ]
[ __ ] well why are you arresting the
person who got the money from the girl
that's uh uh somebody you want on your
team cops are you kidding me she's like
the [ __ ] UH she can convince she
should be a [ __ ] negotiator she
should be a UH you don't want to do it
you don't want to do it man she should
be one of those in the movie she should
play [ __ ] what's-his-name and a good
negotiator the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm out I'm
out dude I'm done she should be a
negotiator man that's it and just she
would get how do you convince somebody
to leave $71,000 because you there
possessed by a demon to it think about
how hard it is to convince somebody to
[ __ ] give up 20 bucks maybe it's not
dude maybe it's not people so want an
answer and and and there hey you know
what dude hey lady who spent this there
are no demons okay there's just people
and if there is such thing as a demon
the only the only person closer to a
demon is someone who would let somebody
swindle them out of $71,000 because that
means you're affecting your family and
you're affecting everyone else and
you're ruining lives of people who
[ __ ] love you so it's all good so
your demon in a way huh right how it all
came back around your demon in a way
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market text me
eight one eight two three two three nine
seventy 87
there's merch you can go get the life
rips will restock them this week go
check now life rips hoodies are all in
stock thank you very much and you guys
are you guys are the best you know thank
you very much for listening okay see ya
[Music]